efforts here locally to hire more
firefighters are heating up as the Clark
County Fire Department welcomes their
biggest class yet Lauren negretti joins
us live from the Clark County training
building with what the recruits are up
to show us some of their moves Lauren
are you going to join the the trainees
there
are going to be back out here later this
morning so we'll see about that but you
know because it is some intense things
that they're doing with those basic
trainings but yes that's right they are
10 weeks into the program now they're
actually back out here again here at the
Clark County Fire Training Center you
know it is a tough program they started
off at a little over 100 they're down to
86 but they're going strong there with
that training I caught up with them
during their burn exercise just
yesterday going over the fundamentals of
a home fire from the fire attack to
search to busting open a door and
ventilating the roof all necessary
skills to address that growing need
we're hiring more firefighters now than
ever you know with retirements Community
growing stations opening up we are just
really understaffed at this point
they graduate at the end of May and
they'll be placed anywhere where they're
needed at the more than 40 stations
across the county here now coming up
while they were learning how to break
down and ventilate that roof I spoke to
a few female firefighters breaking the
glass ceiling we're going to have their
experience coming up here for now live
in Las Vegas Lauren negretti 8 News Now